what in your mind if anything is going
wrong with the brexit negotiations at
night it went wrong right at the
beginning because the government failed
to set the right tone for these
negotiations and I think what we're
seeing now is the incapacity of our
cabinet to decide amongst themselves
whether those who have always actually
thought that plan B ought to be plan a a
deregulated future for this country are
now struggling deeply with those who
think that we need to manage leaving the
European Union in a way that does not
damage our economy beyond repair I mean
certainly despite their claims to the
contrary claims of unity I mean it's
pretty clear that there isn't a settled
view on brexit around the cabinet table
but would you also accept that there is
at least a a degree of confusion on the
part of the public as to exactly what
Labor's position is on brexit look we
said in chios Thomas said you know we
need to do more communicating our
message I mean would you agree
look I'm always keen to communicate our
message but I think what we've been
clear about it is that we need a
transition period that that transition
period should be for the status quo as
it is now in terms of our relationships
with the European Union that that should
not change during the transition we said
that and eventually the government have
come around to our position on this now
having said that there are those in the
cabinet who are kicking and screaming
about it and that's the problem here
they are more focused on their internal
arguments than they are on the real
negotiations and discussion that we have
to have with the European Union but
there's clearly intransigence on the
part of Michele Barney and others that
to a degree you know Philip Hammond may
have misspoke when he called them the
enemy but there certainly wouldn't mind
being characterized as that given given
the way they behave so all of that begs
the question mean what would you do
differently
I mean what would you offer to the
European Union in this negotiating
process that is not being offered by the
government well the first thing that we
have offered actually before it all
started and we said are the very first
thing that we would
do is that we would guarantee the
existing rights of the three million
European citizens who live in this
country and we would look to the
European Union for a reciprocal gesture
for the 1.2 million of our city that
deals that deals that deals with EU
nationals living in the UK but there's a
huge amount more - yep sorry you-you-you
asked me what we would do differently
and I said that's the first thing that
we've done differently and and the
reason for that is because it sets a
tone of mutual trust and that's what the
government failed to do here now there
are many other things that we would be
negotiating obviously first art we would
not wish to be coming out of
organizations like your atom like the
European Medicines Agency we think that
the way in which the government has
approached all of this saying that they
have to come out of all these other
organizations and is absolutely
fundamentally flawed it is it is
creating real problems for the future
way in which we do business next week in
the House of Commons we will have a
nuclear bill coming in - - the comments
simply to deal with the fact that the
government no longer wishes to be part
of your atom this is a nonsense okay
let's move on to something else which
which you could give up I mean how
important is it to free ourselves from
the legal rulings of the ECJ is that a
red light look can I just point out that
in any treaty in any negotiation that
you have where you have an international
treaty at the end here and there it
always has to be a body that determines
whether you've kept to your part of the
difference as the government is outlined
between paying heat to the decisions of
the ECJ and being bound by them isn't
that of course but there always has to
be a binding way of reconciling your
differences now you can have a separate
body the ECJ is without rather more than
that kind of administrative you know a
tribunal body I mean it's a it's a legal
authority superior to the Supreme Court
it guarantees it guarantees rights that
this country keeps in its own
constitution
in Europe is guaranteed they're also so
actually to have a body that says well
this government has said it wants to
bring across all the rights that we
currently possess in Europe into UK law
and to have a body that says here we are
going to guarantee that those rights are
properly delivered to people in any
trade agreement you always have somebody
that is going to be supervising and when
somebody has a grievance they take it to
that body now we can set up separate
procedures with UK judges and even
judges to decide to you the position
that you're outlining the moment appears
to shine without set for by Kirsten
which said like you know pretty much
everything is on the table we just want
to ensure the best at trade access I
have to say though I mean given the way
in which the talks are going at the
moment you know are No Deal brexit is
becoming increasingly likely I mean what
is your view of that it's a disaster a
No Deal brexit is the disaster for this
country it's a disaster because there
would be no clarity for UK citizens
living in Europe or for EU citizens
living here it's a disaster because we
would fall back onto the tariffs and
quotas under the WTO and that would
impede trade in this country it's a
disaster and because we would have
absolutely no certainty for business
you're sure about the future that of the
chairs this morning said that he
believes that the House of Commons would
not permit a new deal brexit well I I
hope that that is true but the point is
this we should we should not absolutely
not have a cabinet that is focused on no
deal even preparing for no deal we
should have a cabinet that his focus is
on the deal but there is a huge logical
inconsistency in that position and it's
fairly straightforward that if you know
the Commons unites to ensure that a No
Deal brexit you know just isn't a
possibility that they would stop it
you know we are essentially being bound
to what the European Union
sees as the negotiated said the
settlement at the end of the negotiating
process if we can't walk away
they just dictate to us look it's not a
question of that what can I go see it in
process in which it is here exactly he
wants to go some distance in giving us a
bit of a bloody nose let me explain to
you the process because the government
talks of no deal as if it's a trump card
that they throw on the table that says
you're not giving us a good enough deal
so so we will will walk away and
actually it's not a trump card that you
throw on the table it's part of the
article 50 process the article 50
process says that you have two years in
which to negotiate if you have not
negotiated by the end of the two years a
deal about your future relationship then
actually you're pushed off the edge of a
cliff into a No Deal which is the WTO
WTO times now what we're saying is it is
that's just what happens it's not it's
not better at negotiating with the
European Union than the government and
frankly I could say that but you could
be a degree of truth in it and I think
it's what I take it take for you say no
that let's return to this listen there's
no deal point because I think I think it
is really important just explain to me
why very very briefly why the coat the
commons voting against and No Deal
brexit benefits us given the
intransigence it could be good because
what it and No Deal is not in our
interest in this is not in the European
Union's interest if the government tries
to walk away into a No Deal then what we
need to do is we need to say no that
should not happen what we need to do is
to extend the period of negotiation and
that can be done under the article 50
only but only the European Union agrees
yes yes and and and they would agree to
extend the negotiating period because
all of us know that there has to be a
future relationship and that has to be
structured around a deal mr. Gardner you
know I admire your confidence but thank
you very much for being with us they
said Sunday morning appreciate it
pleasure